nach soviel erster schultag euphorie
jetzt mal ein garantierter
stimmungskiller die klimakrise ja ab
sonntag ist schon wieder klimakonferenz
diesmal in glasgow passend dazu
folgendes anmeldung noch nie seit der
industrialisierung wurde so viel co2 in
der atmosphäre gemessen wie 2020 im
corona ja das 1,5 grad ziel wird immer
ambitionierter wir liegen jetzt schon
bei
1,1 wissen sie was das heißt wir können
noch 0,4 grad verballern to strom party
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
entschuldigung ich habe mich gehen
lassen andererseits was soll beim klima
noch schief gehen jetzt wo die grünen
quasi schon regieren
ich möchte nicht mehr über klimaschutz
reden
ach so schade worüber sollen wir sonst
reden über deinen lebenslauf
dahin bitte sie meint genug geredet
lasst uns endlich machen die grünen
unter achten sie mal darauf kriegen
jetzt von allen seiten richtig druck
frei des future geht das ampel
sondierung papieren nicht weit genug die
kohleregion die deutschen kohle regionen
sagen früher aussteigen wäre pfui man
stellte sich wirklich nur eine sekunde
lang vor eine regierung mit grünen
ministern drin verfehlt ihr klimaziel
dann heißt es aber ganz schnell ist das
partei oder kann das weg ja
gewöhnt euch daran grüne ab jetzt seid
ihr schuld wenn zb das sauerland
irgendwann so aussieht eure schuld oder
wenn die nächste weihnachtsbaum ernte
schon wieder verdorrt
so hier müsste einen stehen aber das
steht ja kennen also ich sehe dass eure
schuld grüne genau wie die
gletscherschmelze oder wenn josua kimmig
sich nicht impfen lässt eure schuld oder
wenn die feiertage komplett aufs
wochenende fallen eure schuld und wenn
meine playstation immer noch nicht
lieferbar ist wer ist dann schuld die
grünen
ja
[Applaus]
willkommen im erwachsenenleben
so ist das wenn man regieren will 15 der
wichtigsten industrie und
schwellenländer wollen bis 2030 doppelt
so viel fossile energie verbraten wie
ihnen das 1,5 grad ziel eigentlich
gestatten würde im ersten halbjahr 2021
hat anschnallen kohle in deutschland die
windkraft als energieträger nummer eins
abgelöst ausgerechnet kohle hätten wir
mal vor jahrzehnten auf diesen
legendären öko hippie gehört wer mehr
kohle verbrennen will ist ein verbrecher
an unsere bio klimatischen verhältnissen
und man der nächsten generation ganz
recht kinder franz josef strauß war die
greta thunberg der 70er und 80er das ist
eine historische tatsache
dass kohle comeback ist natürlich in
einem windflaute ja die strafe für den
viel zu langsam ausbau der regenerativen
und für immer noch fehlende
speichermöglichkeiten so da wir die
ampel jetzt mehr tempo aufnehmen liest
man ja zwei prozent der flächen sollen
für windkraft ausgeschrieben werden gut
noch wichtiger wer allerdings kürzere
genehmigungsverfahren und noch wichtiger
endlich weniger bürokratie wir haben
hier in der genehmigung 111 auflagen und
eine dieser auflagen sagt dass wir den
ganzen windpark zwischen den ersten
dritten und dem 31 10 10 uhr bei
völliger dunkelheit betreiben dürfen
wie gut das finde ich aber logisch denn
nachts wieder kein wind also das macht
schon macht schon sinn nein da ging es
natürlich um vogelschutz weil windräder
sind ja bekanntlich schlecht zu vögeln
das allgemeinwissen bis bis 2030
bräuchten wir trotzdem jedes jahr rund
1500 neue anlagen an land da fällt mir
ein kennen sie schon diese wunderbare
neue version von don quichote wo aber
diesmal für windräder kämpft ist toll
bereitete alte ritter zum bauamt und die
arme rosinante muss alle erforderlichen
antragsformulare und akten für einen
windpark schleppen auf der behörde wird
er vom zuständigen sachbearbeiters
sancho pansa stundenlang ausgelacht der
erklärt ihm erstmal das förderliche
genehmigungs verfahren mit
öffentlichkeitsbeteiligung nach § 10 des
bundesimmissionsschutzgesetzes
inklusive abstandsregel alles klar weiß
bescheid wann kann ich anfangen fragt er
vier bis fünf jahre später so lange
dauert das im schnitt in deutschland
egal jetzt wird endlich gebaut denke
schotte aber dann klagt leider die
bürgerinitiative zur rettung der
dickbäuchige sumpf holz kröte darauf
wenn es geschosse echt sauer lässt das
kurz an der kröte aus und wird dann
offiziell verrückt in der klapse
beschließt der stattdessen ein
atomkraftwerk zu bauen ende
ein sehr realistisches kinderbuch leider
so und jetzt die schlechte nachricht
damit liegt don quichotte voll im trend
weil die erneuerbaren nicht aus dem
quark kommen wird jetzt selbst bestimmt
auch gelesen ein comeback der atomkraft
diskutiert in england polen und finnland
sollen sogar neue meiler entstehen und
frankreichs präsident emanuel makro will
dass die eu
atomstrom als grüne energie anerkennt ja
sagt paul
weil man damit neue investoren anlocken
würde vielleicht ist das die lösung wir
behaupten einfach atomstrom ist bio kann
man machen
man kann auch sagen schweinenacken ist
jetzt vegan ist alles möglich übrigens
ehrlich gerechnet also - subventionen
etc kostet eine kilowattstunde atomstrom
42 cent bei vinzenz 8,1 cent plus
natürlich das kleine problemchen mit der
atommüllentsorgung ja auf der ganzen
welt gibt es nach wie vor kein endlager
dass die erforderlichen eine million
jahre halten würde solange muss das
leider halten und trotzdem trotzdem
diskutieren wir ernsthaft über ein
comeback der atomkraft
warte mal papa komm zurück hätten das
auch jetzt noch die akw debatte auch
scheiße wir so wieder in den achtzigern
das kann doch nicht wahr sein auch nur
die doofen achtzigern ihr wissen sie
noch wie die heute schon den 80ern
ausgesehen hat
[Musik]
viele ausflüge göbel wieder redet
und habe mir das angehört in brokdorf
ist das neue akw ans netz gegangen das
blöden aber hilft ja nix wie soll man
sonst strom erzeugen mit wind
ja es ist wirklich bitter es ist echt
bitter 35 jahre später brokdorf ist
immer noch dabei meine haare sind weg
gerecht ist das alles nicht meine damen
und herren zum ausstieg aus dem ausstieg
da gerade diskutiert würde sagen in
deutschland sogar die stromkonzerne
ausdrücklich nein danke weil sich nicht
rechnet aber klar wegen der verbockten
energiewende hat kernenergie jetzt halt
wieder fans in den usa kein witz gibt es
sogar pro atom youtube influenza in
deutschland bislang nur einen martin
klempnow
remppis kernkraft kanal
countdown läuft in den nächsten jahres
zieht der harbeck beim letzten deutschen
akw gegen stecker aus der
mehrfachsteckdose absoluter irrsinn kurz
danach kommt die nächste bin flaute und
es wird ab wenn du's mit anlauf zurück
in die steinzeit vielen dank
energiewende dann sitzen wir band in der
dunklen kalten bude und lernen wie eine
welt ohne strom aus sieht gar nicht mal
so schön
aber immer mehr deutsche machen auf es
gibt den verein nukleare aber auch die
orders for nuclear die mütter für
atomkraft sie treffen sich tatsächlich
regelmäßig zum gruppen yoga vor
atomkraftwerken wie hier im grunde
niedersachsen ja ich bin die kinder mit
weil ich habe keine angst vor dieser
strahlung man muss nämlich keine angst
vor dieser strahlung haben wie viel
strahlung schadet mir denn was nämlich
auf einer flugreise zu mir was nämlich
zu mir wenn ich eine banane essen was
nämlich zu mir an strahlung wenn ich
hier bin genau das verfüge werde ich ja
meine kinder wollen ständig in dieses
blöde phantasialand aber ich sage nein
viel geiler wir fahren zum akw
neckarwestheim und trocken uns daumen
parkplatz wir haben alles bock auf
neckarwestheim
und fahren wir nach gorleben
bescheuerte panikmache ja wir haben
keine endlager aber jede menge astreine
zwischenlager brunsbüttel zum beispiel
laut atomaufsicht ist in brunsbüttel
bisher kein radioaktives material
ausgetreten das sei aber nicht
auszuschließen sobald jemand die
verrosteten fässer bewegt bewegt sie alt
und hat auch zu allen wegen der asse
natürlich läuft da was aber ist doch
wurscht die pässe wurden absolut
professionell ein gelage
hier noch drei atom yoga übungen zum
mitmachen
derart homepage
der sonnengruß an alle fans der
solarenergie
diese übung heißt endlager
muss ich jetzt nur noch eine million
jahre lang halten
kempis kernkraft kanal
[Applaus]
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and card
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reicher